hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
number 60. apologize for the late start
our tech has gone
totally 20 20 on us um
merry christmas merry christmas happy
boxing day
happy boxing day i know that one's right
uh will you tell me i
i am old enough that i should absolutely
know this
having grown up around many christians
do i say merry christmas now that
christmas is over
or do i not i have no idea you have no
idea
you don't know all right we'll
definitely have a merry boxing day
since when are you all about protocol
anyway i i it's
i'm a late bloomer in this regard at
least so yes i don't know
i don't know what that's about i think
i'm uh i'm feeling
a certain amount of trepidation i think
a lot of us have been assuming that 2021
is simply going to be
vastly better than 2020 just by simple
matter of uh
reversion to the mean it is very likely
to be an improved year
but there's no telling i mean it could
be that
whatever it is that put 2020 in motion
the way it did is going to continue into
2021.
gee i wonder whether or not that could
be the case whatever put 2020 into
motion the way it did
say the public reveal of a virus on
literally the last day
of 2019 could perhaps follow us into
2020 right
not obeying temporal boundaries that are
in fact entirely human constructs even
while the astronomical realities of
things like
solstices are not human constructs well
i was i was thinking that
the larger context in which covet is
embedded
right might be might be different um
obviously covet is
very unlikely to be cured by the
beginning of the year
and so i don't know at least at least we
have
no presidential elections scheduled yet
in 2021 so it is likely to be better on
those grounds
alone yep but uh i don't know i mean we
none of us really have a good sense of
exactly why
everything seemed to come to a head in
2020
although i have a hypothesis i honestly
have no idea what we're talking about um
can i just stop for a second sure zach
is there any way that we can
um get a view on the camera or is that
just not going to happen
all right it's just a little
disconcerting to be talking into
blackness
okay all right i'm going to save my
hypothesis
go for it please go for it nope i'm
holding it back why what just happened
um let us move on to the material
of the podcast as we had it scheduled so
what was the i'm eager to hear your
hypothesis
i i'm going to hold it to a more
appropriate place
in in the broadcast fair enough um
so we had a i'm trying to remember this
so far this is a very rocky start
welcome to episode 60 everyone here we
are we're going to talk a little bit
about those weird interstitial spaces
between moments that are important
and that mark transitions hey there's a
screen thank you zach
um and uh then obviously we're going to
talk a little bit about locker rooms
and of course and climate change
and the brain cases of shrews and maybe
a little bit about traffic
so you know all very coherent narrative
as
per 2020 right right we'll just we'll
re-kick it off
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number
60. here we are we are staring down the
the barrel of 2021 and
raring to go oh we are raring we are
we're
what is raring i'm not sure yeah the
opposite of well done
i guess do you do you
ever hear that word absent being
followed by to go
are you ever wearing all right on
the couch new year's resolution i'm
inspired my first new year's resolution
is going to be at some point during 2021
at a moment when it's not
wasted i'm going to use the phrase
raring to stop
i like it very good okay well i'm
excited
uh for the moment when you are raring to
stop raring to stop
yes yes all right so um right so we are
yesterday was christmas um merry
christmas if that's still appropriate
merry christmas to you thank you and to
all of you
and uh hanukkah had long since ended the
solstice was
uh four days prior four days prior and
uh and of course the new year
is is coming right up and and for me
growing up
um in a house that celebrated christmas
albeit without very much really any
religious associations with it even
though my father
had faith this week
between christmas and new year's always
had a
particularly um strange
somewhat wistful somewhat sad but also
hopeful
feel to it um you know it's of course
when you're a child
um if you're normally in school you're
not in school right now i mean our
children haven't seen the inside of a
classroom since
march so um this feels very much not
like not nearly as unusual as it
normally would
um but so the fact that that you would
normally not be in school
and that your parents if they both work
normally have at least several days off
um contributes to that but it's also i
think about
just the fact that there are these two
major holidays
regardless of whether or not you
actually celebrate christmas
in the us it is so ubiquitous a part of
the culture
that it is it is all around you
everywhere and
um and by by this moment
hanukkah has almost always come
completely ended i
think there may be some years when it
continues on past um
into very late december and the new year
of course
is both a human construct in terms of
us defining it as uh whatever it is five
days from now
but also reflects an astronomical
reality that is absolutely
um salient and important whether it
would have been important to
you know anyone trying to make a living
on the planet
in any way until until very very
recently it's
only the very strange modern condition
of being human
in which maybe it doesn't really matter
to you that
you've gone a full cycle around the sun
right
um but so there's also this like just
like this this interstitialness of it
it's
it feels it feels liminal uh and i
actually want to return
i don't want to spend a ton of time uh
today
on this question of of liminality but
when
carnival happens when that time you know
and within
actually i don't know what it is this
year but in a few months
um i want to come back to this question
of what carnival is
as someone who has now taken students
into latin american carnival in a couple
of places
and and talk about what this this moment
is sort of shedding identity and playing
with identity is it's almost a return to
childhood
and this moment in time feels a little
bit
a little bit like that like it's got
this potential of
okay as much as that year was whatever
that year was
let's see if we can phoenix this up like
if we can
you know if that thing is going to burn
to the ground what will rise from the
ashes
can we make it something better
unexpected
emergent that maybe no one including
ourselves has imagined before
yeah it is uh it is a weird kind of a
stasis and you know there
has traditionally been a
period in many calendars because you and
i have talked before i think
uh maybe even we talked last week about
the
fact of the calendar being very hard to
calibrate because it's not an integer
number of days
which can be dealt with in a number of
ways you can either physically
instantiate the calendar
where the exact presence of the sun on
the horizon at some location
is used uh as a marker
that marker doesn't move the most famous
one that people will be familiar with
being stonehenge stonehenge but there
are many many of these
uh earth clocks and in fact there's one
i didn't know we were going to be
talking about this or i would have
looked it up but there's one
somewhere in northern north america
there's one
before the population had
figured out how to calibrate their clock
they had tried to do it i think based on
moon
the moon phase which is also not an
integer number with respect to the
year the number of uh complete moon
cycles
and um so anyway there's uh
paleontological evidence of them having
dug up their clock and rebuilt it again
and again and again
trying to get it right um but anyway yes
so
the interstitial space here after the
solstice and before
our new year the new year obviously
being arbitrary
you know as you were speaking it
occurred to me that it would not be
arbitrary if it had been on the actual
solstice and i do wonder if in fact
obviously many their you know calendars
differ um
as to when they place the new year but
this one doesn't seem to be
so accidental and it does sort of
suggest
um a sort of near miss yeah it does
doesn't the start of the year you know
if if it had been uh on the 20th
uh well the 21st um
but i actually feel like there's value
in it so you know you just said between
the celsius in the new year i was
thinking of
really the week between christmas and
new years but it's you know in terms of
astronomical
something uh the solstice and whatever
moment you've decided
to call the new year um still being
reflective of okay one year ago
we were in the same place relative
around the sun and it's a way of keeping
track of your own life
having that delay of in the case of
solstice to new year of
you know 10 days ish a week and a half
um
actually potentially has value right
like it get it allows you time to
reflect and it's not just okay we're
looking forward to this thing and
boom it happened it's over and now you
know move forward
like this it actually allows for a
slowdown and you know most people do not
feel like we need more of a slowdown in
2020
right like there's been there's been
plenty of that thank you very much
on the other hand um as much as
we have been much more at home still
you know not going out not experiencing
things that we would have been
experiencing
all of us as a result of kovit and the
resultant
political and cultural response to it
there is it has been difficult
to get any distance enough to reflect
and maybe maybe we can
use not us necessarily right now but
maybe all of us can use
these next few days to think on what
actually we we personally did
that was appropriate it may have you
know the the
the virus and its downstream effects may
have revealed things about our own
selves
um that are useful to us both in terms
of wow i actually have that capability
or
huh that came out and i didn't i wish it
hadn't and
now i can see it and maybe now i can act
so that it is minimized in the future
yeah so there's there's two things
there's sort of a you know
personal growth you know monitoring from
a fixed period before and then there's
also
a question of you know how different
things are
obviously this year you know basically
it is a year since covid
broke into the world framing
but at some point for example we will
face a year
in which the price of fossil fuels has
changed so much that getting coal in
your stocking is a good thing
yeah yeah okay even if you're a child
you think well
sure i mean for one thing you know it's
worth enough
you can trade it up for a playstation or
whatever it is that you
really want i think our children would
actually prefer the oranges
the oranges oh sure yeah sure yeah um
that's one of the reasons that we get
them oranges that's right
for your whole crate yep yeah absolutely
um yeah so i mean there's there's a lot
to say here about the value of tradition
and about especially at a moment when
it's very hard
to to have many of our normal traditions
to
consider what their value actually is to
not overthrowing them just because
it's what you did as a kid and you think
you've outgrown them or because you
can't see what the value is
you know chesterton's fence in the form
of chesterton's traditions this sort of
thing
and that's not to say that all
traditions have value or need to be
need to be carried forward but think
before you get rid of them and
maybe in this you know unfortunate sort
of whittled down
moment um consider whether or not there
are more that you might
create and establish and they might be
annual
they might be um you know when when
they're daily we tend to call them
habits
rather than tradition you know there's
some there's some temporal scale
long enough uh by which we tend to call
it a tradition
um but even you know seasonal um you
know this
people who celebrate for instance the
astronomical realities
of the solstices and the equinoxes um
have have those as rituals or traditions
and it helps
remind them of sort of yes where they
are
in the seasons but also to say ah
last time i did this i was here i was in
this headspace i was with these people i
felt this way
it's also you know it's one of the
reasons uh that people journal
it's one of the reasons that people you
know leave leave clues to what they used
to think
for their later selves to find because
it actually can
calibrate you and your world perfect
all right here's what i think here's my
hypothesis
this is the one we were going absolutely
awesome okay
um now mind you if this is true it's
important and you need to pay attention
2020 is what happens if you eat the
silica gel
that's the hypothesis so i don't know
who ate the silicon
so you don't think it was collectible
you don't think all of us you know you
don't know
one person eats the silica gel 2020 is
the kind of year you get and so
basically we all need to get on
we got a collective action problem here
to beat the band right we need everybody
to just resist the urge to eat those
little packets of silica gel
just throw them out with the box you
think it was an anti-authoritarian who
just could not take it anymore it's like
do not eat really do not eat
really i'm just gonna eat that yeah
exactly
yeah exactly it was a rebel who uh was
just
um didn't i mean it didn't care the risk
they were putting the rest of us to
had no idea yeah well damn them yeah i
hope it dried them right out
so um we do before we talk about things
uh
totally distinct from this uh we
actually did something this week
um that used to be uh in your life a lot
when you were growing up and was in my
life a little bit
and we had before this week never done
it as a family i had i hadn't
done this in decades um our older son
our producer had been had been taken out
for like an hour once and you had gone
out with our younger son twice last year
two days yep two days um and then cove
would
shut the whole thing down so what is it
and what do you want to say about it
yeah
so the thing is uh skiing which is its
own
weird kind of phenomenon but um alpine
skiing yeah downhill skiing as they used
to call it
um which is uh you know it's a very
fun slightly artificial but very much
out in
the fresh air and in a beautiful place
kind of an activity and
anyway it's been something that has been
hard for us
to do i mean it's expensive it's often
far away
and it just so happens portland has good
skiing within a couple of hours
and so anyway we just finally bit the
bullet and did it and
found ourselves in a beautiful volcano
one lovely wednesday morning
yes on mount hood now toby and i had
sort of
innovated the process you know basically
it's a couple hours away
so you drive there and you drive home
and working from your car
is a whole different way of dealing with
it so anyway toby and i figured that out
last year and then after two days the
ski resort actually made us a deal for a
little bit extra if we just paid less
than one extra lift ticket they would
give us a season pass for the rest of
the season and so we did it
and then coveted ended the ski season
abruptly and
we've been resenting it ever since so
anyway this is our our chance to get
back on the slopes
but um i do want to show you
a couple of pieces of video and then i
want to make a connection which i'm not
a hundred percent certain of but i'm i'm
pretty sure
awesome so zach do you want to show uh
i don't know why don't we start with
toby so this is going to be
toby on his third day of skiing this is
his third day of skiing
ever and this is actually for those of
you
who know mountain hood this is
timberline we're at yep this is
timberline right up at timberline
the resort um and this is you know near
the end of the day
so actually getting a little tired here
but man look at him
three days right
stunning
because the fish who live in water
presumably always have
yes exactly like a mud skipper to mud
maybe would be
excellent better it's less i think it's
going to catch on oh i know it is
um all right uh zach do you want to show
the other video of the
other sun skiing on his first day of
school here's zach this is
this
[Music]
yeah but anyway check this out this is a
guy with
i mean right at the end of the day so
this is less than one full day of skiing
and look at him go amazing no
so i could just be a proud father
looking at my
two fantastically coordinated
suns zipping down the mountain and
feeling a kind of elation
and it might mean nothing to anybody
else but it means something to me
well sure it means something to you um
but here's the
the hypothesis about this both of these
boys
have take have picked up skiing at a
rate that i am
not familiar with this does not look
like you know
a few days in or in zach's case one day
in and let me say before you continue
that because you will not say this that
you
are an extraordinary skier like you you
you just are you skied so much as a
child and then
you went and you also went out as a
teenager with a good friend of yours
who was also an excellent skier and you
pushed and pushed and pushed each other
um so you really you know you know
skiing yeah you are
you're both fantastically comfortable
even after you know decades not being on
the slopes
um but you know what you're looking at
you know what you're talking about so
just to to clarify this i was um after
many years of skiing an aggressive
all-mountain skier uh when i was skiing
with my
you know teenage male friends we pushed
limits and ski places that we shouldn't
have and all of those things
um and then uh you and i got together
you weren't
uh you hadn't done as much skiing nor
was i a teenage boy no
you you were not a teenage boy though
you could give them a run for their
money but
anyway you and i perfected the art of
goofing off on skis
which is he taught me to ski backwards
we spent a lot of time of what's it
called in the slack country
in the trees and the powder yeah it's
called slack country it is now i don't
know
but um but anyway uh so anyway i very
much
uh like goofing off on skis i think i
like it quite a bit more
than i like the the daredevil stuff
which you know
gets old very quickly um but anyway yeah
i do know what it looks like to learn to
ski and skiing has changed a lot there
have been
major innovations in the equipment the
slightly unrecognizable
loop on the top of the boot tongue that
allows you to pull the tongue
up so that you're not in quite so much
pain i mean that is a
marvelous invention how did we ski
before that i don't know
i remember it being painful it was
painful um but anyway
back to the point the point is why are
these boys learning this sport
so quickly and i think the answer and
the boys concur uh they've obviously
only
learned the once but the answer has to
do
they're they are both very coordinated
and athletic but
the other thing is they both have
learned
and are much better than me actually on
electric unicycle which is a
very odd little device very
interesting at some point i'm going to
do a podcast
on it with a friend who is a kind of an
important person in that
little world of electric unicyclists but
anyway
this is a device it's a single wheel
with two
pedals on either side and
it's motorized and basically there's a
little computer in it that
causes it to balance you as you tilt for
oops
as you tilt forward it zips ahead to
get back under you and as you tilt
backwards it would zip
backwards to get under you and you
control the left right balance and you
steer by
you know doing what you would do and the
thing is it's not exactly like skiing
in fact there's one way in which it's a
mind-bending
distinction from skiing which is in
skiing if you put weight
on a ski it becomes your downhill ski
that's how you turn even
before you ever think of it that way on
electric unicycle i believe it is
actually the reverse which is very
strange i think because it is powered
rather than
gravity pulling you downhill but anyway
it's a confusing little puzzle but
but the thing is other than that the
similarities are
many right the way you control the thing
and getting used to controlling the
thing is you're
in the sense of precariousness and you
know you need
you need to have some faith in your body
and in
the in the tools you're using to not
fail
if you're constantly worried excuse me
if you're constantly worried
that something is going to fail on you
you can't you just will never get going
particularly
yeah and um there's something about the
control
of momentum the trusting you know
as you're skiing down the hill you know
you're not you are using the
sort of fluidness of it to
to get down i don't even know how to
explain it in words properly but the
basic point that i want to make is that
the it is weird to find two things that
are so dissimilar
for which one is such a useful
developmental experience
for the other that in fact i don't know
how
fast relative to somebody who had just
never been on either device
this progress is but well what um so as
as you know
i don't i have not yet uh mastered the
electric unicycle
um i haven't i haven't really tried yet
um
but but we're also a biking family we
all we all bike and we all
have um really solid skills on both
pavement and trail on
on bikes and yet you don't raise
biking as a
an interesting and relevant precursor to
to having an advantage and learning how
to ski and is that it do you just not
think of it or do you think that there's
really a
difference in which case you know my
observation that you have to really
trust
the the tools that you're using um
isn't necessarily our proposed because
the same thing would be true of biking
yeah i mean it may be i'm sure it has
relevance in one regard there's
something about um
the experience of
moving at that rate um and
it being safe which i'm sure just uh you
know
inners you to the fear you might
otherwise have on
skis for the first time but i don't i
think the way that you control a bike
is sufficiently different
um you know and also you know maybe what
it is
there's something precarious about all
um
sports in which you have you are
perched over a very low center of
gravity
that the way you control yourself on
skis requires
uh you to deal with um with that in the
same way that a skateboard would or
skates or
any of those things and the electric
unicycle is similar in this regard
um in a way that a bike isn't you know a
bike you can kind of
barrel over large obstacles if you have
you know tires appropriate to it at all
so i think i think it's just it's
distinct but i'm sure then i'm sure
there's some relevance
yeah yeah all right all right anything
else to say about skiing
um i mean no doubt but right now um
yeah there should be i don't know it's
uh it's it's
interesting to return to it after so
many
decades really of no contact with it
yeah now
literally decades i'm sure i was
it was you know early mid 20s last time
i was on skis
yeah and it was just wonderful
and you know obviously being outside it
was a perfect day
it was cold it was cold but it was sunny
and there was little wind
and this and the snow quality was
quite remarkable yeah for for groomed
slopes
it was really nice and uh mount hood and
in fact timberline where we were skiing
is especially um nice it's kind of
small you know i grew up skiing at
mammoth as you did and mammoth is huge
yeah um and you know this is i think six
total lifts but it's interesting it's
you know the lodge itself where you
start is right
at the tree line and you've got this you
know
glorious uh immense peak above and
anyway it's a very nice
uh a nice little place to ski yeah
indeed
all right well um you wanted to talk
we've got we've got shrews we've got
locker rooms we've got a rare bit of
good news regarding
anthropogenic climate change maybe you
want you want to do that yeah
maybe maybe a rare bit of good news
regarding anthropogenic climate change
yep
uh so let's see to get us uh to get us
there
um let us talk about what i think is the
biggest
scary part of the whole global climate
change picture which has to do
with uh frozen methane clathrates
in the arctic so basically methane
gets trapped in various forms one of
them is frozen methane
under the permafrost on land
and under the sea floor and there is
such an immense amount of this stuff
trapped that it dwarfs any contribution
that humans
would make um to global warming
and the problem is that the positive
just because it's not a word that i am
familiar with except from hearing you
talk about it methane clathrates
is the word you're using um and uh
people may also have heard
things like gas hydrate hydra or even um
fire ice yeah in some contexts
if i just thought about it i would have
uh had a
video you can actually see um in
certain places in the arctic um methane
on fire
emerging from sediments and things
uh so anyway you can look that up um and
you can find it but yeah it's basically
these uh
structures these methane structures that
hold uh
they hold methane stable in a frozen
form
it's a
[Music]
they're also chemically interesting i
don't know if you scroll up maybe we can
this is i this is just wikipedia yeah
but they should have a picture of one
chemically somewhere maybe not not
so much okay in any case there i mean
that's just
oh yeah there you go it's too small but
uh yeah yeah there you go
it's um meaningless to almost everyone
so i believe that's going to be
the methane there in the center
but anyway this is a very potent methane
is a very potent
greenhouse gas and there's a huge amount
of it tied up in these
frozen cloth rates in the arctic and
some of it's under
permafrost some of it's under the sea
floor but the danger
is that it's in a it's stable because
it's frozen
and as the earth warms it is going to be
released at some rate
and what we have seen there's a
particular a russian uh
academic outfit that does a lot of
studying of methane releases and they've
found these
in siberia mostly yeah uh in the uh the
ocean
um it's a it's a it's a marine census
oh maybe different so they found these
huge plumes
of methane and the problem is we don't
have good baseline data like
do you expect huge plumes of methane
if so are they more common are they
bigger we don't know
i probably we know more than last time i
checked in on this but
we because we don't have a hundred years
of
data on these methane plumes because in
general they're not of consequence
we it's hard to say how alarmed to be
about the fact that there's suddenly
huge amounts of methane
bubbling up in the arctic but the danger
is
that we could get to a place where
positive feedback would take
climate change completely out of our
control
because to the extent that it gets
warmer than historically
it has been it will release faster yeah
warmer faster
it will release a bunch of methane that
was frozen that would otherwise have
stayed frozen
that methane because it's a very potent
greenhouse gas will cause the following
year to be that much warmer
that following year will then release
more methane and so what you'll get
is eventually a release of a huge
fraction
of that stuff and at the point that that
happens
there's basically nothing we can do
right this is no longer a question of us
controlling climate change it's a
question of us adapting to whatever is
coming
at whatever magnitude um and so
uh that uh dragon's breath
hypothesis is or though that's what's
the clathrate gun hypothesis the idea
that it would go off like a gun
is a very frightening prospect and those
of us who are most concerned about
this um happening are have our eye
on this and my contention has been the
day
on which climate change is no longer
something that we could control even in
principle
it will not make the news we will not
know it has happened we will not know
that threshold has been crossed it will
just happen and then we will
live downstream of it but it might not
even be deducible in retrospect
right like you know five ten twenty
years later pinpoint it a little bit but
um i think we will have a sense of it
now we're doing enough monitoring
but it's the the point is it's a
it's a threshold we will cross but it's
not you know it's not a threshold
that can be named specifically i believe
in the present
it's too too complex so what emerged and
actually i
owe my good friend kevin
um a shout out for pointing me towards
this but zach could you put up the
actually before you put up the article
could you put up the pictures of the
craters
the yama craters you can just start with
any any of it
okay so this is the floor of
one of these craters in the yama
peninsula of
siberia um could you go to the next one
uh here's some people rappelling down in
so you get a sense for how big these
craters are
go to the next one okay so here you can
see from above and
uh those of you i know i talked about
this on the podcast with katie herzog
these craters are i believe
very ominous and i think that the images
of them ought to be on everybody's mind
i don't see these images nearly often
enough given what they
suggest um the these craters were
discovered
i mean i guess we saw a person in the
last one so we're talking couple
hundred feet across 100 feet across
these were discovered ironically enough
by fossil fuel petroleum workers who
were traveling over the yama peninsula
by helicopter and they saw these holes
in the ground
initially we did not know the
explanation for them
the dragon's breath hypothesis that this
was somehow
an explosive release of methane um was
tested and turns out to be the best
hypothesis probably true
for what created them and the idea is
this is such an unpopulated region that
there are no people around to report oh
yeah we heard that
we went and looked and that was never
there before right there are no
eyewitnesses to these
correct craters being formed correct um
now i will say
the yama peninsula is pockmarked by
geological processes so how rare this
actually is i don't know but it is
certainly rare within geological
experience in fact it's so rare
that this particular formation does not
have a name
right so we have names for other things
and in fact there were
hypotheses that this was a pingo pingo
being
a geological formation that arises when
water freezes and ejects uh
dirt out of a hole um but it doesn't
look like this it's not explosive right
it's
just like it's a cracking mass of dirt
and it would be there rather than
there would be dirt remaining right um
so this is not a pingo
it turns out it's probably due to the
explosive release of methane and that's
very frightening because what it tells
you is god damn it there's
you know there's stuff going on on the
methane release from the arctic channel
that is profound in terms of its scale
and knew enough that we don't have a
geological name
for it right as studied as geology is
this is new
so that's scary and we ought to be very
worried about it
so in light of that having
yeah why not uh that's still the guy
repelling
is there a fourth picture okay
um so now could you show the article
so my friend kevin forwarded me this
article
which i cannot read at that scale um
yeah and so anyway this
um suggests something which may be
the rare piece of good news that we get
on the
climate change front what this uh
article
describes is the discovery initially
about tides and their effect on methane
release and basically the idea was the
highest so the moon
here in the ti in the headline title is
just about the moon controlling the
tides
yes okay that basically the moon's
effect on the
height of the water column above the
frozen cloth rates controls how much
release the more water is standing on
top
the less likely the methane is to be
released which stands to reason
certainly so there's
it's not a binary are you covered with
water or are you not
it's actually the depth of the water by
which you are covered is predictive this
is a continuous variable the depth of
the water by which you recovered
um is actually uh
the the greater the depth the more
protective against uh clathrate release
right which is is what has been observed
or it's a hypothesis no no this has now
been tested okay
of course always could be reversed but
yes the idea is the more water that's
sitting on top of these uh these methane
hydrates the less likely they are to be
released the smaller the plumes that we
get and the reason that that is good
news
is because it suggests a negative
feedback
on methane release which is to say if
you take the scenario that we described
up top
where methane release or something else
causes the temperature to warm
that warming temperature then causes
more methane to be released which causes
it to
warm further that's a positive feedback
there's no controlling that
it will be controlled by some other
process the
water on top however is something
sea levels you all know are slated to
rise if the temperature goes up
why because the ice that currently holds
a lot of that water
will flow off the land and into the sea
causing
elevation sea level that's a bad thing
especially if you live
on the coast it's a bad thing for lots
of reasons but
it may have this positive outgrowth
which is
it will increase the depth of the water
on top of the methane that is the
greatest danger
in this whole global climate change
story so therefore
the warmer it gets the more water will
be on top of the methane clathrates the
harder it will be
uh for it to be liberated so it may be
a buffer rather than an accelerant of
climate change wow that so that that
would be terrific news
uh these clathrates uh which are it
sounds like littered across the
what peninsula the the yama peninsula in
siberia
this is this is tidelands or it's
dry land but low lying such that even
with
relatively small amounts of sea level
rise they would potentially be submerged
as always when we do this off the cuff
there's the danger of my saying
something
dumb but it is uh
arctic permafrost um
so these are it's dry land um
low lying and uh basically it's tundra
tundra is i think the right term arctic
permafrost which could therefore become
sort of
marshy if things warm up right
maybe depending on where the water table
is what the elevation is and also yeah
and i i have no doubt actually that some
of it is marshy some of the time but
there's a perm
there's a permafrost layer that is uh
buffered from the sun and uh below which
resides an awful lot of methane
apparently oh the test i should say the
test in those craters involved
descending into those craters to detect
the levels of methane which were sky
high
um so anyway yes a rare piece of good
news one and
you know i must say in in the better
discussions of climate change
that i uh haven't done it recently but i
participated in
years ago there was always this sort of
hope
that buried somewhere in the complex
system
that uh controls the earth's temperature
was a hidden feedback that we had missed
that could work in the right direction
and while this probably isn't sufficient
in fact
you know it is the warming that it is
the rise of sea level that brings the
protection so that's not a good thing
but nonetheless it is a feedback that at
least i had never heard of before
um that would work in our favor rather
than against us
well just fabulous hope it's true yep
um hope we don't need to rely on it yeah
it would well
be great for us to get our ducks in a
row one way or the other
um my sense having
thought a lot about all that we might do
is that
mitigating the release of greenhouse
gases
it's too little too late um and that
really our
only plug-and-play hope
for reversing what we know is coming
is fusion power fusion power if we can
if we can get there actually would allow
us to pull carbon
out of the atmosphere right you could
actively pull it out yeah you could pull
it out of the atmosphere the way trees
do for example but you could do it as a
result of a process in which you could
basically use huge amounts of
energy liberated from uh between
uh these uh subatomic particles
um and that you could use that you can
make building materials out of co2 in
the atmosphere and use it for something
useful and
lower the temperature well yeah probably
we're not investing nearly enough
infusion power
to get there in time i don't know why
we're not i cannot imagine why we are
not
investing more in it um we are
investing you know small not tens of
billions of dollars which sounds like a
lot until you realize
compare investing hundreds of billions
of dollars you know
globally in things like text messages
um so anyway yes we are being very
foolish not to pursue
fusion yeah um hopefully we'll get there
um let's talk briefly about shrews of
course
yes i mean it's that point in the
podcast where
the mind shifts to the subject of shrews
and other insectivores
and other insectivores okay so let's
let's just start there with a brief
phylogenetic note from
uh your sponsors deep history um so
shrews are
insectivores which um sounds like it's a
description of their diet
because we have these this language of
like carnivore omnivore insectivore
uh foliv or herbivore um but they're
we are using that term in its phylogenic
meaning and so and actually
actually um i made a comment maybe last
week or or two weeks ago about the
carnivorous with whom we live
and um that is not a standard use of the
term that is actually that was a student
of ours
brendan brendan um who in talking about
the difference between ecologically
eating meat
being carnivorous and phylogenetically
being
part of the lineage from which um all
extant carnivores
uh being part of the lineage who had a
most recent common ancestor from which
all extent carnivores
members of this clade belong those are
called the carnivora
but not all the carnivora not all the
carnivora
eat meat there are for instance fruity
dang kinkajous
some of my favorites um and there are
plenty of things that eat meat that
aren't in the carnivore
right so there are the carnivorons which
include basically the feliform ones
which are like cats and hyenas
and weasels and such and the cano form
ones which include dogs and bears and
seals and
lots of other stuff uh yep so
people who caught your explanation there
this will then make sense of the fact
that snakes
are tetrapods by virtue of the fact that
they are in the tetrapod lineage without
being quadrupeds
right so even though tetra and i don't
know which is greek and which is latin
but tetrapod and quadruped mean exactly
the same thing
right but four four footed in this
family
we segregate these two things so that we
can talk about snakes being tetrapods
without
tripping over it um but quadruped refers
to things that actually have
four legs exactly so snakes are
tetrapods who do not have four legs
because they are part of the lineage
tetrapoda um kinkajous are carnivorous
without ever eating meat because they
are part of the lineage that includes
um all of the carnivorous and there are
insectivores in sectivera um and
actually gosh there's some new
latin name for that clade i think i
think that clade turns out not to be a
clay
it's not a clay it's a paraphilia oh
it's not so we're talking about the oh
boy
yeah so i don't even remember then who
belongs where
um but but what rest assured we'll
figure it out and get back to you on
that
what truths are not is rodents they're
not rodents okay so um you know half of
all mammals are rodents more than 2 000
species of rodents on
on the planet another quarter of all the
mammals are bats and that leaves every
other single thing you can think of
that's a mammal
in that remaining quarter and the
insectivores which includes
um shrews are included in that quarter
as well
so shrews have little tiny heads under
the best of conditions
and it turns out so there's this polish
zoologist
august danelle this is old news in
zoology and i'm just learning about this
this week and given everything else
that's going on i'm not sure exactly why
i was so
taken by this um but i just kind of
can't think
stop thinking about it ago stanelle this
polar zoologist
made the observation back in 1949 he's
long since dead
that the not just the
brains but the brain cases the actual
skulls of shrews
shrink in winter and regrow in the
spring
okay are you looking for a shrew skull
yeah yeah i'm sure we have one somewhere
i do have one but i'm not sure where it
is um yeah we're always misplacing our
true skulls
so often yeah and so that
that it became known as dannell's
phenomenon the fact that shrews
um shrink their brain cases and also
apparently their livers and their
kidneys
and that's amazing but there's something
about the brain case itself the
literal the skull shrinking by 15 to 20
or so in the winter and then regrowing
in the spring that's so remarkable
but danelle only observed this he didn't
he didn't do what's called a match pairs
experiment he was just looking sort of
population-wide and noticing
that i think it was museum specimens
that died in the winter
had smaller skulls than those that were
alive in the spread that died in the
spring and summer and so maybe this is
just about
selection acting differently on animals
that had smaller skulls in the winter
and
and on the in the summer but in 2017
um so again not totally new
we find this published in current
biology profound reversible seasonal
changes of individual skull size in a
mammal
and these guys did the work they they
tracked individuals
much to the dismay of the shrews no
doubt
oh and to their significant others who
no doubt
thought this was kind of cool the first
time they heard it but then dinner time
after dinner time they
kept i was certain you were talking
about the pair bonded shrews and their
significant others
oh i can't speak to that i mean yeah so
they're opinions
i don't think these shoes are
pair-bonded yeah i don't think so either
no but the authors here might well be
and i'm sure they were sick of here is
this are you are you saying to me that
you wish i would stop talking about
shrews
no no no on the contrary i'm imagining
that
in general the significant others of
these
true studying biologists were not
themselves similarly interested in our
case no i'm i'm all for this discussion
yeah it's really it's our children who
are downstream of our enthusiasm but we
are equally enthusiastic about
um the skulls of shrews shrinking in the
um zac
yeah give me my screen back um so
so they actually demonstrated it um for
sure so this
uh this dunnell's phenomenon um turns
out to be true and apparently there's
some
evidence from weasels too which is
fascinating because weasels as per our
conversation
you know five minutes ago are actually
carnivorous so they're um
not very closely related to shrews um
and
i guess the reason that i am so
surprised by this
yeah go for it here i got it
uh well i don't got it but i got a piece
of it
if i'm remembering my mammology
correctly both shrews and
weasels do not hibernate
this is absolutely true so this this has
been observed
uh the shrews are apparently eating some
crazy multiple of their own body weight
every
every day to to maintain themselves and
winter it's harder to come by food and
brains are very expensive to feed
and if you just shrink your brain and
not your brain case and it's going to
rattle around in there and not be not be
very effective come spring so you're
going to shrink the whole thing
so you know in terms of what the
adaptive advantage
might be i i can see that although it
also feels to me like everyone else is
also hungry in winter and if you've now
got less brain by which to evade
predators
this might be challenging for you on the
other other hand shrews
emit some odors that make them quite
unpalatable to at least
mammalian predators i don't know about
hawks and such i don't you know birds
birds have such different sensory
most birds don't it's traditionally
thought as you know
most birds don't have uh a very
sophisticated sense of smell they're
they're exceptions
right like uh vultures but right and i
don't know about the uh
the you know like the exciters the hawks
and such
um falcons um
but the the reason i find this shocking
honestly is because we have in
organismal biology are pretty old i
actually didn't go and look in the
history to see how old our understanding
of
the terms determinate and indeterminate
growth are but
this what these terms mean
is if you have determinant growth at the
point at some point
as you reach adulthood you hit a size
and you do
your bot your skeleton does not grow
anymore you can obviously grow out you
can always you can always get fatter
um but your your um your long bones
don't continue to extend for instance
right
and you know we got sort of three types
of skeletal stuff but i think even the
um the cranial skeleton really doesn't
you know just doesn't your
your appendicular skeleton and your
cranial skeleton your um
and your axial skeleton are all there
and this is this has been understood to
be
what mammals have and what birds have
determinant growth
there is maybe not a predetermined size
because it's going to be
affected by things like diet and
environment but at the point you hit it
and some other developmental things
happen you don't keep growing
compare that to organisms with
indeterminate growth
which include most you know fishy fish
crocodiles
squamates like lizards and snakes which
actually do keep growing um continuously
um throughout their lives now that rate
of growth um
slows dramatically and it almost looks
asymptotic like it almost looks like
they're
approaching some some size at which
they will stop but but they don't it
seems like they just they keep growing
and that's called
indeterminate growth so if we were
seeing this
like brain case shrinking in winter and
then regrowing again in spring
in an organism with indeterminate growth
like a crocodile
that might be scarier than a shrew but i
wouldn't be so shocked by it like
whatever is going on with regard to
skeletal growth and development
in like crocodilians is clearly
different it's more
labile it's more flexible over the
lifetime of the organism than it has
been understood to be in mammals
and this thing that we're seeing in true
suggests at least some mammals have this
ability
to not just turn back on
change in in bone but actually reverse
actually go smaller yeah which i i just
didn't even know this was possible
well frankly blown away by it my guess
would be
that there's a whole landscape of this
stuff that we just don't know yet
because it's not that obvious
100 um and there's you know stuff in the
neighborhood right like
uh antlers you know antlers are bone
true true that doesn't get resorbed it
gets dropped
and then regrown but there's some
something there
so just a feeling so yeah it's not it's
not resorbed but
um but you do get you know something
about
male development prompts growth of new
bone with a
with an ability to then drop them at the
end of the season yep yep okay
um so one thing i want to point out
though is that this actually
is reflective of something that you and
i have long
argued in many contexts which is
that the any hypothesis
about brain size that does not include
the understanding that brain is the last
thing
you want to be big without a reason
right
that any size that you find in in the
brain
is there because it served the ancestors
uh whose uh existence
caused it that very clumsily said but
the uh
the fact of the brain having grown
larger over time
cannot be explained by any drift-like
cause because but gee brett i thought we
only used 10 of our brains
right exactly that kind of nonsensical
claim just doesn't stand up scrutiny
because
a the brain is so freaking expensive to
run the most expensive organ
in the body the size of the brain case
makes it
vulnerable right so the bigger it is the
more likely you are to crack it and die
yeah and it wildly increases mortality
for women and childbirth
wildly increases mortality for uh women
in childbirth
and the hip widening decreases stability
of walking
right forces the baby to be born early
which causes a period of helplessness
which is much harder for the parents to
deal with
um the loss of heat is proportional to
the size of the brain and heat is
a the huge expense it's something like
85 percent of calories for endothermic
that is warm-blooded
creatures like ourselves so the point is
the number of things that push in the
direction of cheese if you can get away
with a smaller brain then do it yeah
is huge so do we get a pin headed true
if you can
yes be a pinheaded shrew if you can now
there's advice for you
we'll all take that one into 2021. um
but anyway so this does suggest that
there's intense enough pressure on these
things that even within an
individual a seasonal opportunity to
shrink the brain however that works
is a good thing yep and that selection
has found it
uh it sounds like maybe twice and maybe
twice yeah which which
then of course raises the question of
like really just twice are we sure right
and it probably won't be but then here's
the question
i want to know you know the thing about
the brain
is it's not like more is good right
more is good by virtue of how
the neurons are connected to each other
so exactly what way
are these creatures economizing and then
rebuilding
what sort of structure is it that they
can rebuild a brain that's of any use at
all
right what are they what are they losing
access to right like what can't
they do in the winter that they can do
in the summer and
yeah i actually okay so so do i
yeah it's a little bit poorly formed but
i got it in my head yeah
so i had two things one is
maybe they're not losing the neurons
maybe they're basically collapsing the
structures
intact so there's a weird uh result
in development where
the cells of the baby are present
long before they are fully infused with
resource
right and so the point is the research
you don't put the resource
pregnancy is dangerous and you don't
want to put the resource at risk before
you have to because
that's you know a penny saved as a penny
earned metabolically speaking
and so uh is it possible that the brain
is being shrunken in size
that basically you know the the way but
they're still walking around
well right obviously there are lots of
parts of it that won't be but yeah
are there sets of circuits as opposed to
fully lost
right as opposed to lost and then
regained which is mighty hard to imagine
how that could be
productive um it is um
on the other hand uh we know that for
instance migrating songbirds
literally lose their testes and regrow a
pair
upon landing in their northern migrating
their northern breeding grounds
because carrying around balls is too is
too heavy to fly with for these birds
and so you know the thing that i was
wondering about shrews is is whatever
you know if it's lost rather than shrunk
down or either way really yeah
it's partially going to be about sort of
whatever the true equivalent of mating
and dating is
you know that they don't need in the
winter exactly that was going to be my
hypothesis also was that there was a
whole
uh you know complexity surrounding
reproduction
that you know you're not going to need
but again i wouldn't imagine it would be
uh lost i would imagine it would be gold
storage as it were
yeah but in passing you just blew right
by oh no regrow a pair oh no i i
yes regrow a pair now that
is an insult perfect for an era
in which so many people are losing their
ability to say
normal things in the face of a crowd of
people
shouting at them and i i think i'm going
to start telling people to regrow a pair
oh i have actually
i've i've begun doing that occasionally
yeah yeah it's a good one
it's a good one i like it yeah um yeah
it has broader applicability than if you
were a
bird landing in his northern breeding
grounds i think there are a lot of
contexts in which we grow a pair is in
that case you're just being supportive
that's where you grow a pair right in
fact yeah i mean if the right bird
looked at you and said regrow a pair you
know it'd be a good sign
absolutely yeah get on with it buddy
yeah exactly get on with it
exactly all right well are we there with
the uh the shrews
and i i think we're there for the shoes
yeah i think we've done shrews
we're at an hour already good lord oh my
goodness um
how did that happen even um well we
probably do want to talk about the uh
the transgender kerfuffle in the
evergreen locker room of all places
of all places yeah um so
how do we want to do this we want to
show them the
cairo video well let's just say yeah
set up very briefly and then we'll show
you a two-minute-ish video from local
news
uh up in olympia washington our former
home for 15 years
more than that um and then we'll talk
about it
so i don't know you want to set it up
well sure all right so
let's be you know as always we need to
make an effort to be
completely fair about this let's just
describe what apparently happened and
this will be largely uh in the video
also but
apparently a trans woman that is someone
born male
um and you will hear them stumble over
that very claim
in the news report but not the person
not the trans person no
one of the parents no well actually she
does too but anyway yes the news report
says that this person was born a man
nobody's born a man
nobody you know what i'm saying yeah one
male 1 yeah born male would be
the traditional way of saying that in
and not assigned male either born male 1
right so anyway sorry we're not doing it
no we're doing a terrible job
this uh trans woman
born male transitioned to female as an
adult
was apparently in
the locker rooms at the evergreen state
college now evergreen
is a college but those locker rooms were
being
rented out or somehow local high schools
and swim teams with elementary school
kids oh i didn't know the elementary
school as young as sex
so these girls from these schools
encountered this trans woman
who has not surgically none of them
not pre-op either non-op no intention
to have surgical change so
male genitalia in a female locker room
where a middle-aged man where there's
teenage girls and younger
right and some of the girls apparently
uh reported this to their parents and
the parents
requested that something be done to get
uh
the situation remedied and anyway
um the remedy oh
yes there's maybe we should just show
the video at this point
zach do you have it
the person at the center of this
controversy says she is being
discriminated against
forced to leave a facility she has a
legal right to use
i looked at her and said excuse me and
she said you have to leave i'll be right
back
colleen francis says she was using the
sauna and women's locker room inside the
recreation center
at evergreen state college two
wednesdays ago the same facilities used
by two
female high school swim teams from
olympia who practice in this pool
a woman told francis to leave she
wouldn't identify herself she all she
said was that
there were a couple of girls that came
upstairs to the pool and said that
there's a man in the sauna
but francis who acknowledges she was
born a man says she has lived as a woman
since 2009
still someone called campus police and
local parents got wind of it
they're uncomfortable with him being in
there her being in there and
they are a bit shocked by it christy
holterman's daughter was one of the
swimmers
holterman complained to evergreen
college officials tell us they have been
working with the olympia school district
which leases space at the pool but state
law requires equal access to state
facilities
regardless of sexual orientation so
local school officials tell us they came
up with a temporary solution
there's a smaller private locker room
next to the the main locker room there
at the pool and they've been using
that but francis says she believes the
students need
an education this is not 1959 alabama
we don't call the police for drinking
from the wrong water fountain
but all right so
there you have it um
so this obviously raises
interesting questions and um
creates a pretty good uh
illustration of why inventing
pronouns and forcing some kind of new
usage
is not a solution
to the problem did you notice this that
the uh
spokesman for evergreen there
says that the college has attempted to
come up with a remedy and that it has
found some other locker rooms
that they now use and it is unclear in
the report whether they
refers to the girls
of these swim teams or whether they
refers to the single individual in
question
now in fact in writing
they remedied this in a clumsy way but
in the written piece you
they clarify it in parentheses and they
say that in fact
it is the swim teams that are using
these separate
smaller less good facilities
because of this one
person who in a separate report is
revealed served in the military for 20
years
and is now wearing a low
estrogen patch and lipstick
apparently and that that is i i'm sorry
this makes me so angry well you know
so you know we've talked about trans a
lot
in a lot of places i encourage people to
look at my
letter wiki exchange with abigail
schreier
if you are concerned that i'm not being
respectful we have trans friends
we say over and over that trans is real
and actually one of the
i think the first question we're going
to get to in our q a this this next hour
is
some people who are really concerned
that you know what could we possibly be
talking about when we say that but
um create a system that's gameable and
it's going to get gamed
and how dare any system put
girls and young women at risk because
a dude wearing lipstick who has sort of
girly affectations
wants to be in the sauna with his bits
hanging out
it's not okay yeah i i'm not okay i
agree it's not okay
i'm not you know i'm not sure uh
her name was revealed i think there's no
harm in using it
um colleen here you know i'm not sure
that the onus is on her to
um figure out how to navigate this but i
do think that the institution
has an obligation to protect those girls
first and foremost
well uh as as
was the case in 2017 when what happened
at evergreen happened there
um it is not primarily the individuals
who are spouting garbage
fault it is the responsibility of the
so-called adults
to walk in and say you're spouting
garbage and you will stop now and we are
going to take whatever power you have
rested illegitimately away from you
this person colleen is it has the
freaking audacity to say this isn't
alabama 1959 i think is the
random year that she comes up with
rather than i think 57 is probably what
she
55 you don't remember um
no it's not and frankly
a guy with an estrogen patch and
lipstick
is not a black person using
a drinking fountain a guy with an
estrogen patch and lipstick
naked in a sauna with a bunch of
girls it's a different situation and
everyone knew that until yesterday and
this is something we talked about
this is you know douglas murray's
formulation like it's it's one of these
things
that we all knew until yesterday and how
is it that we are all pretending that
the emperor has clothes
emperor has no clothes here um
so i agree with you i still think the
onus is on the institution
and while i think it is very clear
for many reasons some of them biological
that the analogy uh to the drinking
fountains is completely out of place
it's despicable well is it despicable
it's despicable that this person would
claim that they were fighting a civil
rights fight when what they're actually
fighting for
is the right to be naked in front of
young women she shouldn't
be in that locker room you and i agree
on that the question is
this is on institutions
as a reflection of the rest of us to get
this right
and to prioritize those who actually are
in need of protection
and so in this case what you have is
somebody born
male right now why is it
that um women have their own locker
rooms why is it that they have their own
you know divisions in sports and
you know why prisons right we that
exists because males
for reasons it's not our fault but the
fact is
uh evolutionary history gave us
a power advantage and that power
advantage
in the case of
sexuality also creates a special hazard
for women not only
are men in a position to overpower women
on average but the
harm of having done so um is
that much greater now this is partially
historical but just the simple fact
of women carrying pregnancies means that
the the jeopardy here
is all the greater so do women deserve
protections
from men yes they do right for reasons
that aren't any of our fault
it just happens to be the situation
there's an asymmetry in the biology and
that asymmetry
justifies a protection that protection
does not reverse because
you decide that you're female or because
you feel female
and therefore the institution absolutely
has to provide protections to these
girls rather than
what they have apparently done here
which i can't say i'm all that surprised
given how frequently this institution
flies in the face of logic on such
things but has prioritized the rights of
this
individual trans woman that is to say
born male transitioned to female they
have prioritized
her rights over the rights of numerous
girls who are both disadvantaged by
having been born female and therefore
likely being smaller
are disadvantaged by virtue of their age
right
and so they are actually vulnerable and
so what i want to be careful of
is when i saw that interview with
colleen here
i thought the fact that she acknowledged
that she was born male didn't seem
sensitive about it was willing to talk
about
the fact that you know one of these
girls had apparently
complained about a man in the locker
room she talked about it in an adult
fashion so i was you know i'm
sympathetic that there's actually
potentially something to be solved here
but there's no question
who needs to be protected in the
situation from whom
right i don't know that colleen is a
danger i assume she's not
but the fact that we segregate women
because somewhere
in amongst men are men who are dangerous
means that those protections should
should remain no matter what yeah
i i'm gonna end up ranting
if if i if i say much more about this
wow so you know
a 16 year old girl who walks into a
women's sauna
naked and sees someone with a
[ __ ] and balls and reports that there's
a man in the locker room
the person in possession of said [ __ ]
and balls not being offended
that someone saw them and identified
them as male
that's a really low bar there's a really
low bar for being impressed with this
person's response well
come on look i do i do think we um
because and i agree with your uh
your assessment that we have you know
this is a dangerous thing to say but i
believe it is a literal thing
and that you're quite right about it
that you have the phenomenon of trans
whatever it may be
and then you have a bunch of people
utilizing
the um opportunity to opt
into two oppressed classes that is to
say trans people
have a difficult road based on
uh perceptions of them and females
are are able to avail themselves of
protections
for the reasons we've already described
and so the ability to opt into two
protected categories is irresistible
for some men and they will do it there
are unscrupulous men and
they will do it but i just don't don't
know i
never want to assume that that's the
explanation
into something that can be revealed in
some cases i guess
just one more thing and i did allude to
this earlier but um
this case makes my blood pressure spike
in part because the interview which we
showed you guys
um has
this person
doing little sort of girly things
with their hair and their necklace and
like this and
this feels like and i'm not the first
it's not the first time i've said this
i'm not the first to say it and it will
be said many many times again
but this feels like the most regressive
and misogynistic view of what woman
is that i can i mean maybe not the most
misogynistic and regressive view
what woman is but it's incredibly retro
it's incredibly woman-hating actually
like that's not that is not doing this
doesn't make me a girl
right no that's not what it is it
reduces it to an affectation
yeah yeah exactly and there are there
are plenty of us women out here
who don't do that and there are plenty
of women who do
and in neither case does the doing or
not doing
things like playing with our hair make
us a woman
no and if like if if you're a dude who
wants to play with your hair
and act that way okay but there is no
way in which that makes you female no
no all right but i still think
the the object of our ire
really ought to be these um ridiculous
phony progressives who actually
imagine that in some biological sense
that you um become female
by virtue of having uh declared
uh declared a pronoun or two and i
i think we ought to refer to them as she
jerk liberals
[Laughter]
so oh boy there's that okay she jerk
liberals she took liberals
yeah um i think you know there's other
places we could go but i think that's a
good place to stop for today
actually on that bad huh she no no not
good
she jerk liberals all right okay well
yeah uh i guess we have then
reached abruptly the end of this 60th
live stream on the dark horse podcast
yes um yes no i think i think we have
tomorrow actually is our private q a so
we are gonna we'll be back in 15 minutes
for those watching with our our q a
um here today but tomorrow is our
private q a where we do
um a two-hour private q a for questions
that have already been asked by
patrons um on my patreon and if you join
um before tomorrow at 11am pacific um at
the 5
level or more you can join uh in that
conversation it's small enough that we
have the chat visible to us and we can
actually look at it unlike
any of these live streams you
have your 100 patreon conversation
for a handful of people next saturday
before this live stream
you're looking at me like holy hell
didn't i just have one no no i'm
you said for yeah it's more than a
handful but it's a nice
uh a nice group of people two hands and
two feet falls
something like that yeah something like
that
fingers and toes yeah i presume they
have fingers and toes
i don't know yeah um so you can you can
find access to that at brett's patreon
um you know there's there's merch listed
there but but uh all the
we're going to bring it out some new
stuff at some point soon
so rather than talk much about that if
you have logistical questions you can
email darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com um you can access the discord
server at either of our patreons
and we have a clips channel that uh is
putting out clips of what we talk about
in these longer forms
uh nearly daily at this point i think
yeah lots of stuff
lots of stuff and uh so
please join us in 15 minutes and if you
are listening only
we will be back in the new year awesome
all right merry christmas if it's
appropriate happy new year
and uh we'll see you shortly one way or
the other be well